e
good morning everybody if everybody
would please take their seats it's 10
o'clock
thanks
Karen okay
good being 10 o'clock I will now open
the all right I believe this is a public
hearing work session okay um the the
work s the work session for House Bill
10:39 relative to Alternative sentencing
for primary
caregivers um so in the past we have had
smaller subcommittees for inim study
bills and those smaller subcommittees of
course discuss it make their
recommendations and come back and we
vote on it as an entire committee and
after discussing with uh chairman Roy he
decided that you know he feels that
we've pretty much already had the
discussions and they just kind of come
back go over them you know rather
quickly as a committee and what I'm
going to do is open each one we'll talk
about it I'll close it we'll go to the
next one and then we can break out we
can go to our respective caucuses and
we'll come back and make the
recommendations from there so with that
being said um house B 1039 relative to
Alternative sentences for caregivers I
am opening it up for any discussion
representative Murray good morning good
morning thank you Vice chair roads um I
was just going to share that um I am in
conversation with the Coalition against
sexual and domestic violence over this
topic right now um because they named
some concerns if we were to um to
implement this bill with our current
system as it is so I want to work with
them to address those concerns before we
introduce legislation like this again so
I would say we we not recommend it
moving forward okay
anybody
else representative Reed thank you
chairman uh Alexander what were your
questions your concerns regarding bring
your mic down what were your concerns
regarding this this bill that you feel
need to be worked
on from my understanding um the
Coalition doesn't think that we have the
support systems in place to make
alternative sentencing a viable option
at this point and that we need to build
out our basically our systems of support
before we can um Implement something
that's going to bring more people into
the community without the support
systems necessary um yeah to make that
safe for
everybody representative Newman yeah I
just want what what Coalition did did
you say it was that you uh dealt with
sorry Coalition against sexual and
domestic violence thank you
anybody
else all right well seeing none I will
close the work session for House Bill
1039 and I will open
the work session for House Bill 1428
relative to inmate illness or emergency
and again I will open it up to any
discussion anybody have any
thoughts okay uh does anybody yeah
representative scitec this is this is
actually back before but I just wonder
about whether we want to recommend this
legislation or the topic for um further
legislation what exactly is our
charge so if it's specifically about
this legislation sure but that doesn't
mean the topic isn't worth pursuing is I
guess my point so if representative
scitec you know obviously if you know
our our job if I'm answering your your
question specifically is to basically
because we in inm studied the bill is
does the committee as a whole feel that
this that this particular bill is worthy
of legislation in that event then
somebody would be charged with writing
the legislation and reintroducing ing it
whenever we all come back in January you
know those that are fortunate enough to
come back or unfortunate enough I'm not
really sure um uh you know but basically
really today what we have to find out is
do we think that this is should be
recommended or not recommended and
that's it we don't do anything else with
it and if the person does want it to be
you know come back then they're going to
be the ones charged with doing that
close enough
okay so does any does any anybody
even recall what this was
repres representative cig thank you very
much mam chair um my recollection is
that this was a bill that we had a lot
of opposition to and a lot of discussion
around how safely to transport prisoners
to medical facilities without putting
further
strains on departments uh Sheriff's
departments among other things um I I
couldn't find my notes when I was
digging through my piles at home but um
I just had this Rec my recollection is
that the sheriff's Association was not
necessarily in favor of this one because
there were so many complexities to
trying to make it work but I may be
wrong representative Stone thank you
madam chair uh it's my understanding
that this bill was brought to basically
give the authority of transporting
prisoners that are already incarcerated
to medical appointments by Correctional
staff which if the committee is not
aware most of the Cy Correctional
Facilities have transport teams that are
armed and trained to do such I think the
sheriff's department was looking at it
as it was a drain on some of their
smaller departments size-wise and that
the correctional staff might be better
attuned to doing it than the sheriffs in
various counties but I could be wrong if
somebody has a better recollection I
think that was the purpose of this bill
if I see you give me one second so this
is starting to come back to me a little
bit as well wasn't there conversation
about
some of the smaller towns that may only
have honestly one or two police officers
and was this is when uh individual is
incarcerated and they have a medical
issue that the correctional staff have
the capability currently I believe all
10 but uh if someone has more
information I know locally Sullivan
County has a transport team that's armed
to do their armed transports for
prisoners and they have a dispute over
should the sheriff's be responsible for
doing all the transports or should it be
the correctional staff Who currently do
it with Federal detainees when they do
have Federal detainees because the
sheriff's departments generally will not
transport Federal detainees that are on
a per DM rate at a County
facility I see that now thank you for
the clarification representative Murray
um I I pulled up the notes we have from
the hearing and this was actually only a
minute or two long hearing where the
prime sponsor came out and asked that we
hold it for interm study because the
bill needed more work um so I it sounds
like yeah that's literally one sentence
that's why having the clerk is good
so it was the Prime sponsor that asked
the stum study it because he didn't like
the way it was written basically okay
all right anybody
else all right well with that we will
close the work session for House Bill
okay so we will open the work session
for House Bill 1462 relative to
requirements reporting hate crimes and
representative Murray you'd like to
talk yes so originally the chairman and
I held this um in case we needed to use
it but um Senator Chanley passed a
similar Bill essentially um when I
drafted this one the AG didn't have the
full information that we then got later
amended Senator chand's Bill and passed
the legislation that way so this bill
isn't necessary at this
point so so when we're ready to go
you're basically recommending not you're
just recommending no future legislation
okay let me put my little
note anybody else we
good all right well we will close the
work session for 1462
okay we will open the work session for
House Bill 1500 relative to prohibiting
the unlawful distri distribution of
misleading synthetic
media and I
will open it up any
discussions representative Murray what
do your notes
say Madam chair I I
oh I was just trying to raise my hand I
I was the uh co-sponsor of this
legislation and we moved this interim
study because the chair and many
legislators felt that a commission
around AI is how the legislature should
move forward and whomever is elected
speaker next year I would hope moves
forward with that and a similar style
Commission because the issue is
important but how to get it done as
where the opposition comes in from there
was opposition from the media um I
forget exactly what their Association
the broadcasters Association and um they
don't there's concerns around free
speech and uh criminalizing satire and I
think those are genuine concerns so I I
think recommending no further
legislation would be appropriate and uh
pushing whoever gets elected speaker to
appoint a commission along those lines I
think would be better than trying to
force through legislation thank you
representative Willer I I will add to
that that I do remember there
was three or four if not more pieces of
legislation that were in various
committees not just ours I think we had
two um
additionally Judiciary also had a couple
and I I feel like somebody else had one
as well I'm not really sure God bless
you whoever did that um and I do I'm
recalling now
that there was discussion I was was
there there was a couple other
representatives there um somebody there
was a representative from election law I
think I think it's representative
Brennan but I don't want to say that if
it wasn't true but I'm pretty sure it
was her representative Lynn was there
myself um and a couple of others the
speaker was also there and we did
discuss this and the question was about
you know the difference between like
you're saying satire
or almost an actual threat and I I do
believe that was the the thought process
was to come back with something that was
going to that was going to address all
of it not not just kind of you know
patch a couple of leaks that kind of was
happening with the bail so this was kind
of similar to that and I do believe we
did pass something on the house floor
about this already though so we probably
don't need to keep on going with it I
think you're right representative
wheeler um hold on one second
representative Newman did you have
something you wanted to say or you just
had your notes okay representative
Newman yeah I just have a question about
the process so this appears to be a bill
that it that we probably wouldn't
recommend for this bill to go forward
but the subject matter appears to be
worthy of a bill so we if we voted yes
we would be voting can we vote Yes that
the pro that it's worthy of of a bill
and then somebody would just do a bill
or would we have to do a bill
so what we do today is we make a
recommendation basically on on the bill
that we have in front of us so even if
we say that we don't particularly think
that it should be recommended that
doesn't mean that anybody regardless if
they're in this committee or another
committee can't say I actually think
that there should be some legislation
and and write that so I I don't think
it's as simple as
yes or no yes it is this particular bill
but it also is a subject matter right um
but as we all know you can you can write
the bill for anything that you feel
needs to be addressed and if it's this
subject matter you're welcome to do that
but today we're voting on this bill
whether or not we think should be
recommended to continue yes or no but
yes or no on this Bill thank
you well it's the third time it got
asked so apparently there might be more
than just yes or no uh representative
scitech did you have a
question okay all right anybody
else all right well we will close the
work session for House Bill
1500 and we will open the work study um
Jesus the work committee
for oh wait hold on I have them my bills
are not in
order wait a second I got to get to
it I have to get to
it all right so House Bill 1566 relative
the review of police
investigations okay so this was the bill
I do remember specifically I'm sure that
we all do
um unfortunately there there was um some
deaths
involved
and the the family members were very
very passionate that things were not
done
correctly and you know we heard from we
heard from law enforcement we heard from
people in that
Community I don't know at the end of the
day that there's going to be any
answer that is going to be sufficient
for a family member grieving a child I I
I just don't um I know I recommended
that the bill be itl because we do have
you know many there is a lot of
processes that are in place um this
particular situation did go through all
of those channels and unfortunately the
answer was just not ever going to be
what what that family needed
um I actually recommended that we inter
terms studied it I'm sorry that we ited
it and then it you know basically we
just agreed to interim study at that day
you know my recommendation would be that
we do not recommend it for future
legislation um but of course we're not
making those this moment but
representative wheeler
Ching thank you madam CH I just wanted
to add having worked with the family uh
in helping them speak with the executive
branch and meeting with the Attorney
General's office and um going through
this legislation with the governor's
office and the attorneys General's
office I I do believe that
um this is an issue in legislation worth
moving forward on um I think
that the technical opposition that was
offered for this legislation with all
due respect to those who did I think was
offered more because of how emotional
the situation that particular situation
was but the family made it clear that
this wasn't about their situation this
was about uh making sure that there was
accountability and um I'll be voting
against a motion to not recommend any
further action on this legislation
because of that and I I think that
accountability is important and having
worked with the governor's office and
the AG on this uh I I would think that
this legislation
is fine to move
forward representative
Manion thank you um it's a difficult
subject taking the emotion out of it
this um is not about accountability was
it was made clear that they didn't think
the jry police department did anything
uh that that resulted in misconduct they
just didn't like the results of the
accident reconstruction report it was
reviewed by the county attorney and the
Manchester Police Department also did
their own independent reconstruction of
it with the same findings so this is
more about the findings that they
weren't satisfied with um if there's any
misconduct done in the police department
the state police or the Attorney General
are going to investigate that aw is not
needed to do that this was simply about
you didn't like the findings or you
didn't agree with them so you want
someone else to take a look at them um
and this and in this case here they want
the state police to look at it what if
the police state police came back with
the same
findings we just ended there so this
isn't really if I remember correctly not
an accountabil ability bill but more
about we didn't like uh what the
findings were
so representative
n thank you madam chair um I think the
conversation that we're having is
talking about a specific issue but the
point is to implement A system that
enables people to have um to have an
independent review I we talk about how
the independent review or um a quasi
independent review was done and that was
a process that you know put the family
in this specific situation through uh
the process of having to fight for that
whereas what we're saying is we're
saying that should that should be
automatic that should be something that
if requested should be done so we're
saying it was done and they weren't
happy with the results well if they
weren't happy with results that's that's
not what we're legislating here we're
legislating um the capacity for someone
to to be able to have an independent
review without having to fight for it so
I I would vote in favor of this bill
com representative Murray on thank you
madam chair um first I wanted to note
that um when Manchester Chief of Police
Alan aldenberg testified he talked about
how um there is already a process for if
a victim feels the local police
department did not do an adequate
investigation that they can go to the
public Integrity unit at the AG year or
go through the County Attorney as
representative Manion mentioned um and
there already are processes in place to
have you know a further look into an
issue like this um I guess
representative wheeler wanted to hear
more about these conversations that
you've had with the AG and governor's
office that make you feel like there is
more room to to push here
I hold on one second representative
wheeler representative Roy had a comment
and I had to call on representative
Marie first that's okay you can go ahead
and answer her that we keep
continuity representative wheeler
so Maryann scotus the woman who came to
testify who had the
specific issue that were that the bill
was proposed around wanted to meet with
the governor's office and I relayed that
and helped meet helped her meet with the
governor's office those conversations
were around this bill and what they felt
could potentially be wrong with the bill
uh what the systems were implemented the
AG wanted to know about this uh
situation itself what particularly might
have gone wrong there um I don't I don't
know where those conversations went
beyond me sitting down in the executive
Council chamber with the representative
from the AG's office and uh Harold
Parker from the governor's office but I
can say that both the governor's office
and the attorneys General's office was
very at least in that meeting open to
hearing what this legislation was about
open to what their situation was about
and I think that the Family itself was a
little upset just by uh being taken on a
bit of a rigorer ro by the state
government and I and I think that that
happens to plenty of people not just
this one particular family I think
people in the state government are um uh
not as open to hearing stories from
constituents as some of US
representatives are and as a result they
can be flippant not listening in in
conversations and that can create
friction that leads to um people feeling
like their situation wasn't properly
addressed and I I think that's what
happened here the as far as I understand
the governor's office said to me on the
house floor and we almost had um change
on they they said to me that there was
no they didn't see any issues with the
text in the legislation is what Harold
Parker had told me um whether that's the
governor's official position or not I
you know Harold parkle told me that in
the on in the hallway and I'm not saying
it is with all due respect to Governor
shunu um my point and I think
representative nle Illustrated this
properly this isn't necess this isn't
about at all actually their situation um
I think Maryann scotus would say that
too this is about making sure that
there's in law codified uh a system of
accountability which as I mentioned in
past testimony on this legislation does
as you mentioned exist in police
departments across the state already and
I think this legislation codifies what
uh already exists and if you know the
difference of opinion comes some some
people think it's already working and it
already exists some people think we
should make sure it's codified so that
it
works representative Roy thank you um
couple couple things so first off I'm
the co-sponsor of this bill and the
prime sponsor came to me and relayed the
situation we're just talking about um
and hearing that I said wow that that
does sound pretty messed up um that
sounds like we could this sounds like a
decent idea so after agreeing to
co-sponsor I I started doing research
and seeing okay what's the current
situation you know if we have a bill we
may need to modify it and and it's
pretty much as clear as mud um there are
systems in place but no one really kind
of knows what they are except for the
people who are dealing with with them at
the moment um so first of all like I'm
right now involved in two separate
incidents similar to that one with
constituents where they feel like they
really didn't quite get a fair Shake be
it because someone might be perceived to
be in a position of power or have money
and all of a sudden inexplicable things
are happening that you would think
common sense says they may but then
again on the other side you talk to a
county attorney he says no we we looked
at it so the issue is is that the person
who's
upset isn't able to know who to talk to
to find out what was actually done and
what was looked at so as far as this
just to be clear our job here is to
recommend to the legislature as a whole
this is a good idea or a bad idea
whether someone picks it up and runs
with it is really not us but I would
recommend to anyone who thinks that this
is a good idea to start with a study
committee because this is a very complex
issue to you can't there's no way you
can just write a bill and say for
example if people feel like well I I
should have someone to go to if I don't
like the outcome of the investigation do
you realize the amount of work that that
would generate for the State Police I
mean it would be hundreds and hundreds
of cases a year would double their work
so there would need to be criteria that
would make that um eligible for that
type of thing so there's a lot of little
moving pieces that would have to be
looked at and I would encourage whoever
it is to get the county attorneys to get
the chiefs of police and to get um
victim witness Advocates get everybody
together so that they aren't talking
past each other and even they understand
what the current lay of the land is so I
I would definitely recommend looking at
it if someone wants to first as a study
and I mean a real study um because it's
got it it's got so much complexity to it
that a simple piece of legislation
written without that I feel like would
either be ineffective or worse it could
lead to worse outcomes so that that's my
take on the whole subject thanks
representative celik thank you so much
and to echo part of what um
representative Roy said is the idea of
the lack of understanding of the process
my recollection the part of the
discussion was there was so much
confusion on the part of the family
about where to turn to next and as I
tried to understand the process and
spoke to different people it didn't seem
like there was Clarity so I would
encourage if anyone did pursue this
further
that part of it should really be about
how to communicate effective ways of
tracking the information like having a
maybe that's where the codification
needs to come in is what are the steps
that people can take how do we
understand who our person is that we
reach out to I think that having public
comprehension of how the process works
is is crucial just just asn't there was
another law we had about you know stop
stopping uh people taking breathalyzers
and much of it was just people don't
understand the current law because they
don't remember from when they were 16
years old
so it's a different that was a different
law but there was confusion around that
one for similar reasons it's kind of
scary a 16-year-old have to take a
breathalizer uh representative
Newman as as I read this law I came
across my pet peeve for legislative
language and I agree that this is a good
idea it needs to be studied and I would
have the people that look at the
language in the bill look at one word
and that word is
shall shall or may when you take May and
I don't know what the current law says
but it probably says may request and
this says shall request and that almost
makes it a requirement so you need to
figure out which one of them do you
really want and I in my think thought
process is is probably still to be a and
think about what happens with the bill
and all the recommendations that said we
can approve it so that's my
thought thank you representative Murray
thank you madam chair um I just wanted
to make clear that this doesn't codify
an existing process it institutes a new
process um like representative Roy said
it would add a new greater burden on the
state police which is not what the
process is right now so this is isn't
about codifying something that's already
in place um it institutes a whole
different process I agree this issue
deserves more study and I think there
are definitely things we can do to
improve um you know communication
between law enforcement and victims and
make sure that everybody has a path to
you know at least understanding the
result that they got um but I definitely
do not think this legislation um in its
current form is
that anybody else good all right I will
close the work session for House Bill
1566 and change seats
I hereby open the uh work session on
Senate Bill 244 relative to bail for a
defendant ohcap 1 248 relative to bail
for defendant um I'll I'll just kick it
off by saying that um I'm I'm really
tired of that word um the b word bail I
think I think I think we've done
everything we can and we need to sit
back and let's see how this works what
we've just put in place was extremely
complex um I think it was extremely
benef official for the citizens in
Hampshire and E any further tampering
with that at this current point before
it takes effect in full and we see how
it works would be very dangerous but um
open for
comments I said let's kill it yeah well
we'll get we'll get to that um with no
further comments I I think that we'll go
ahead and close that work session and
it's right for um voting on this
afternoon with that I open the executive
the work session on Senate Bill 3 21
relative to lease a defendant pending
the
trial and I um wish to just reiterate
what I just said any further comments
discussion seeing none I hereby close
that work
session I open the work session on
Senate Bill
415 relative to the penalty for certain
fentel related offenses um this one's a
little different now this is I believe
if I recall this was the one that would
make it a felony for is this the one for
possession or importing does anyone have
that you have it
possession
possession so this one surely we have
some opinions on
um I do believe and this is my my
personal opinion from observations I've
seen over the last six years that we
have tried um we have tried and and it's
worked to a certain extent various form
forms of mitigation of harm mitigation
um we've tried the testing part I I
believe our overdoses are way down
because we've um got the um I almost
said the antidote but the
um
Naran out into the public at a much
greater rate our police officers all
have it our EMTs all have it and I
believe citizens are actually can get it
now and carry it so that that's a that's
a big
plus we do not want to criminalize in
any way addiction addiction is disease
just like alcoholism bar various mental
illnesses but we do have to find a way
to interdict the flow of drugs into the
state and the people that are pedling
this and making profit off of people's
suffering because at the end of the day
all the things I just listed in the
mitigation or the harm reduction and
mitigation are all treating symptoms
it's like you know taking taking Advil
for a headache but not understanding
it's because you have narrow arteries
you're going to have a stroke I I think
we need to stiffen the penalties to show
the public how serious we take this
fentanyl problem it's being manufactured
out of the outside the country um it's
almost impossible to stop be it to a
border or FedEx or UPS it's just there's
so much of it um we can't keep up so at
the same time as we hope our federal
Partners will do their job and interdict
this stuff coming in it's getting here
we need to send a message that we are
not going to tolerate the poisoning of
our children in this state and I think
that it is worthy of of legislation to
make that message clear especially in
light of the fact that many of us want
to legalize
marijuana we we have to differentiate
those two things we're not saying we
approve drugs now we're saying this is a
substance similar to alcohol
that can be used in a certain way this
is always poison always so I feel like
that differentiation needs to be clear
sharp and to the point um with that I'll
open for conversation represent n thank
you Mr chair um I think especially you
know given what we had heard from um
people who came in and testified who
work in the recovery community and
things like that um I I agree that there
should be a distinction um but I think
that that is very difficult to make in
uh for two reasons number one because
fenol is pervasive it is in everything
and we have implemented some testing and
analyzing strips that's one thing um but
it requires people to have knowledge of
how much is in there the other thing
that people spoke about um was the idea
that people's tolerance uh changes and
so when we talk about a definitive
amount that varies per person so
individual people who are not uh
trafficking um individuals who who as
you said um struggle with substance use
disorder something that we you know uh
acknowledge as a you know mental health
and and things like that that that has
physical um ramifications on the body
that changes your uh your physiology
what happens is when people's tolerance
goes up because of those um physiolog
physiological changes that um this
number that we are putting on it to
Define what is the difference between
someone who is um a user and someone who
is um um uh trafficking that number
becomes very very fuzzy um and then what
we end up doing is because we have set
this number we have ens snared people
who just have a uh uh an issue that has
further progressed than maybe others um
and their tolerance is up thank you
representative Murray thank you Mr chair
um I just wanted to share that no one
came and testified in support of this
bill when we had the public hearing um
and additionally the way this is written
it includes the dilutant for fentanyl in
this measurement um which if you know
you know cannabis can be laced with
fenel so for example it would be really
easy for someone to get charged with
this mandatory minimum who had cannabis
maybe knowingly or unknowingly that was
Lac with feny because it would be a lot
easier to get to 5 gr of cannabis that's
Le fentanyl than just 5 G of fentanyl
it's not about just purely the fentanyl
do includes the
dilutant I would just clarify that a
dilutant is um the definition is
something that dilutes it makes it
weaker I don't you can't put marijuana
into fentanyl to dilute it you would add
fentanyl to marijuana so I don't think
that that would count I think dilutant
would mean um with cocaine it would be
like um or it could be cocaine that's
the dilutant it could be with like you
would use baking soda delute cocaine I
think that that's what that that means
but your point is taken um
representative
Newman I want to agree with
representative new we do need to send a
message mandatory minimums are not the
way to send the
message thank you representative roades
thank you Mr
chairman so we have heard a lot of
mention about dealers don't know what is
in it or what they're necessarily giving
somebody but they clearly know that
they're giving somebody drugs and a
deadly substance right and somehow we as
a society have sent a message that
depending on a person's
status is whether or not we're going to
charge the person that delivered a
deadly substance with a crime so I will
refer everybody to a Hollywood actor
that died in a hot tub
right he clearly had a
disease they charged the dealer and he
was arrested right so the message was
well he's more important than people in
Manchester people in New Hampshire
people in Chester County he's not any
more important he made more money
probably than all of us but he wasn't
more important the same thing
happened with a very popular singer that
died right they charged the people that
gave the deadly substances so we're not
talking about charging the people that
are taking the deadly substance that's
the issue of recovery we are talking
about the people that are knowingly and
willingly giving these deadly substances
to our children to our parents to our
grandparents and people are dying this
isn't making an excuse for the person
that's doing it it's holding those
accountable that are willing to kill our
community
members thank you I just want to add a
couple things um based on what I've
heard um we often put a lot of um a lot
of emphasis on who came and testified
and who showed up and who didn't and
that is worthy of not among many factors
but keep in mind that I as a as a
advocate for this um 30 3,400 people
showed up in the person of me and 34
more hundred showed up in the person of
Representative wheeler maybe against it
so we have to remember even if no one
shows up to testify against the bill in
this room we've got you know 30 40,000
New Hampshire citizens speaking so it's
important to not downplay our own role
in this um second of all um with regard
to what representative Newell said about
the the amount um that is definitely
something that the new piece of
legislation would have to look at five
grams of fentanyl would kill everybody
with probably within five square blocks
of here if not more so is that enough to
say that you're a dealer because you
have that much or if you are using to a
certain amount that that might only be
two days worth for you so I think some
scientific answers have to be put in
place before we arrive at a number I'm
not sure that that was done I think a
lot of times we just pick numbers based
on you know how much how much will this
kill how many people will this kill the
question is is because of Tolerance how
much can a single person take before you
could say that's no way just for you so
I I I I advocate for this legislation
but I advocate for science to back it um
yes representative thank you so much I
just I have uh one echo of
Representative Newman and one question
one is just that historically we've seen
that mandatory minimum sentences
ultimately cause more problems than they
solve and I would invite whoever chooses
to move forward with this legislation or
similar to look at alternative ways that
allow judges who we appoint for the
purpose of having their discretion use
it in an appropriate and suitable way
and just be able to consider whatever
factors are necessary in making
sentencing that doesn't mean it I I
don't support criminalizing the behavior
or increasing penalties but I just mean
I think we need to keep in mind
mandatory minimums don't generally help
problems and the other is I would invite
anyone who's reviewing this um as a as a
woman of a certain age and having had a
conversation with a gastroenterologist
recently where they talked about one of
the methods of making sure I wasn't
awake during a certain procedure would
be incorporating fentanyl into an
anesthetic program so that the medical
uses of certain drugs that we would not
want on the street are not accidentally
uh being
criminalized yeah well I I don't I don't
believe that um people with a
prescription for fentanyl would be
caught up in that um I would say that
fentanyl is a common drug in a hospital
as a matter of fact um when I used to
work as an investigator for the Board of
Medicine down south um one of the first
cases I caught was a ER doc who was
diverting fentel out of a crash cart
because when you intubate somebody
fentel is the first thing you do and the
horrific result of that is people were
being intubated without it um which can
cause enormous stress so fenel is is
does have perfectly great uses um and I
don't think that legislation like that
should catch that up in there um one
more thing on the minimum mandatories I
think we're going to agree to disagree
on that I think that um statistics
depending on who you who you ask um or
or which study you look at show effects
both ways but I would rely on the
gentleman who came here who had already
served time as a drug dealer and he said
you want to stop the reason we didn't
used to come up here and deal in the
Hampshire is because we knew you had
minimum mandatories when those went away
the drugs came with them so maybe
anecdotal but it's certainly worthy of
consideration um anyone other hands on
this one
seeing none I'll close the work
session and with that I
will open the work session on Senate
Bill 425 relative to bail commission
fees um I think we've dealt with that we
gave them a nice little bump anyone want
to talk about
it seeing none I closed the work
session next I open a work session on
Senate Bill
464 prohibiting the consensual
non-consensual dissemination of a syn
sexual synthetic image and I open that
up for discussion um I'm not sure if it
seems like we had a lot of bills
regarding this last year I'm not sure if
anything actually made it through or not
um if it didn't I would I would say that
we probably should look at it if it did
we should wait and see what comes with
that Mr chair
yes uh there was a bill that was passed
and signed um it was a house bill not a
Senate bill and it was pretty much the
exact same bill
if I recall that was the one that
representative Muse was talking about or
sponsored yeah representative Muse my
myself and a couple other couple other I
don't know on here but yeah okay so if
we got one passed we should wait and see
how that works any comments questions
thoughts seeing none I will close the
work session with that I open the work
session on Senate Bill 578 relative to
criminal pre-trial services and
monitoring this is again a bail kind of
issue I think we dealt with this already
does anyone want to talk about this
bill represent wheeler I would just
really quickly mention that I do think
criminal pre-child services and
monitoring are an important step forward
in the long-term thinking for the state
to be moving for I mean the budget next
year is going to be a little tough but
in the long longer term thinking about
bams moving forward once we have a more
stable economy and things like that I
think we do need to start looking into
similar to how we did here last year
updating the criminal justice system in
ways and I think the work that's being
done in straford county and the other
counties across the state around
pre-trial services and monitoring show
that that might be one of those ways too
I I actually agree I believe that the
bill package that we sent forward and
was signed in law tasked the uh
commission for criminal justice to um
actually look at pre-trial services and
see if there was a Statewide model that
they could use maybe a straford to
someone else and come up with funding
methods to help reimburse counties who
chose to adopt it so I think we're I
agree we need to head down that path and
at least uniform so that um your level
of services that you get don't depend on
what ZIP code you get arrested in so
repr
n um just a point Thank you Mr chair um
just point a clarification because I
think that with this bill it it doesn't
aim to implement pre-trial monitoring
and and things like that what it does is
it says that if you cannot pay for it um
it should be paid for if you are
Indigent then it it should be um P that
you should not be responsible for the
cost of it right if you if you can't pay
for it so that's the question that this
bill is asking it's not whether we
should implement it it's how it is
funded and whether people who cannot
afford it can still have it without
being able can still Avail themselves of
that option um uh and and not be stuck
with a giant bill I think well that that
opens a whole new can of worms in as
much as any pre-trial services that are
offered are offered on a county bycount
basis and the county governments fund it
so I don't think we would be able to
tell the counties you can't charge
people for it that's an unfunded mandate
so we would have to come up with fund
every thingle every single piece of it
and since it's not uniform one County
may be giving amazing stuff that's very
expensive and another County may not
have much so I I think this the answer
to the question you just raised has to
be part of a uniform pre-trial Services
across the state I would I would think
but thank you anyone
else yes represent s thank you I don't
actually have anything on this bill but
one once you close the hearing if I
might be allowed to make a very brief
announcement to the committee that would
be great sure um seeing nothing further
I hereby close the work session on
578 we will convene again at 1: p.m. to
vote on these it shouldn't take more
than 10 or 15 minutes
um well I would I would first of all
disagree with the uh Stupid um I didn't
know how long these would take so I had
to plan had to give it time I I don't
know if I can I'll have we can't no it's
noticed in the calendar and that's when
it has to be one o00 um so yeah that
gives us a couple hours um if you can't
go if you can't stay as long as we have
a quorum just make sure you let me or
Linda know um as long as we have a
quorum okay well I am sorry that you are
unhappy um any further comments none uh
representative s go ahead thank you so
much um I sent an email out to the
committee which hopefully ever everyone
received about an event that I've
brought um through my other hat to UNH
later uh this fall it'll be October 23rd
it's a presentation called aftermath
which specifically talks about pts and
First Responders so there's a scripted
play reading followed by a facilitated
discussion and I just think it's a
really valuable program I wanted to make
everyone aware of it it is free to
attend we do have a sign up just to make
sure we don't overfill the room um and
I'm happy to share information with
anyone but I just wanted to make sure
you all saw it because I think it's
something worthy of all of our attention
thank you for sharing that with us and
bringing that to our attention and if
you don't recall it check your emails
it's in there uh representative Pratt
just what was the location of that it
will be at the University of New
Hampshire in Durham okay thank
you um I think the the email had the
exact address and you could link it and
it would take you to a web page so that
would probably be helpful with that I
will see you all at 1:
p.m.
e
e e
okay
everyone um we're just waiting on one
person who had to use the ladies room um
based on the number counts today I
believe that um one side is going to
Prevail so I'm going to recognize that
side to make all the Motions um that way
we're not doing a double vote count um I
we're out of here at 1:15 if anybody
wants to talk we've already discussed
these bills today um you can you have a
right to discuss them but I'm leaving
and you can continue without me um so
let's get this quick done voted okay um
hold
on represent Ro let grab
something I will take I'll make the
motion on all the bail ones and I'll
write the report on those because we
already agreed that we're going to
dispose of
those but everything else you guys can
make a motion
yes um I would say I would make a motion
that we vote this um for future uh we
that we make a motion to recommend this
for future legislation or or not yeah uh
I think we'll figure out what you mean
all right with that um I open the
executive session on house build
1039 and who would like to make the
motion representative Balden recommend
uh HP 1039 for future leg legislation
yes very good thank you um I believe we
discussed this earlier um anyone have
anything new Dan okay seconded yeah we
got
that um based on that I would ask the
clerk to call the role the motion on the
floor is recommend for future
legislation Vice chair rhs no
representative Pratt uh no
representative SCU
Representative jandrin no representative
Manion
no uh representative Reed no
representative Stone absolutely not
representative
Gite uh representative
Balden absolutely
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative sik yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chaires
no motion carries 9 to8 is that
correct representative mail yes motion
extra Carri 9 to8 UM representative
Balden um please have that um report or
sentence or whatever you want to give me
by the end of the week
please um with that I close the
executive session on H HB
1039 I open the executive session hb1
1428 would anyone like to make a
motion representative stone make a
motion not to recommend for future
legislation
1428 seconded by representative
rhods um anyone need to add anything to
what was discussed earlier seeing none
i' ask the clerk to call the role
what was your motion yes not recommend
yes say
no Vice chair
roads yes representative
Pratt uh yes representative scitec
representative Janan yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
Harry gother no representative Balden
representative sorry that was I'm sorry
okay representative
Veil no representative Murphy no
representative Newman
no the clerk
votes
yes representative
newel
yes I know we're voting yes to say no
right
yes representative selling
uh yes representative
wheeler chairman Roy I don't know um yes
I think
yeah something 13 to4 the motion carries
to not recommend future ration
representative Stone if you could have
me a blur by the end of the week uh with
that I close the executive session on
House Bill 1428 I open the executive
session House Bill 1462 relative to
requirements for reporting hate crimes
uh anyone like to make a motion
representative uh Murray I recommend
um or vote to not I motion to not
recommend this for future
legislation second anyone seconded by
representative s share hand up first
okay um anyone need to say anything
about this do you want to say anything
that we haven't already said seeing not
I'd ask cour to call the role the motion
on the floor is not recommended for
future legislation oh excuse me
representative
Newman yes to say no yes thank you it's
like going left to
right Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone representative Harry gother yes
representative
Balden yes representative Vale yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative selling yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
chair votes yes 170 unanimous vote
motion car carries of a recommendation
of not recommended for future
legislation that I close the executive
session on House Bill 1462 I open the
executive session on House Bill 1500
relative to the prohibiting of unlawful
distribution of misleading synthetic
media anyone for a
motion represent roads thank you Mr
chair I make a motion of not to
recommend um House Bill
1500 I'll second second to
representative man anyone need to talk
about that we already discussed it
that's the one that we just passed and
was already signed into law um no
discussion please call the
RO motion is not to recommend for future
legislation Vice chair Ro yes
representative Pratt yes representative
PR or sorry s
yes representative janen yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed representative Stone yes
representative Harriet goth no
representative
Balon yes no it's
not no representative Vale no
representative Murphy
yes representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative celik yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes yes
152 by Mo uh 15 to two the motion
carries it is not recommended for future
legislation representative rhs if you
could by the end of the week with a
blurb with that I close the executive
session on House Bill 1500 I open the
executive session on House Bill 1566
relative to review of police
investigations and I recognize
representative Manion for a motion oh no
excuse me representative
wheeler thank you Mr chair I move that
we recommend HB 1566 for further Le
legislation seconded representative
sake um I believe we discussed this one
pretty deeply as well anyone need to add
anything see not ask cler to call the
role the motion is to recommend for
future
legislation that's yes Vice chair roads
no representative Pratt
no representative
scitec Representative jren no
representative Manion no representative
Reed no representative Stone no
representative Harriet
gther yes yes representative
Balden I feel like I just want to recuse
for the rest of these it's so
confusing
uh abstain no um whatever Linda said
thank you
yes representative Vale yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy the chairman votes no with
reservations 98 98 the motion carries it
is recommended for future legislation um
representative wheeler if you could have
me a blur by the end of the week please
I can do that with that I close the
executive session on House Bill
1566 I open the executive session on
Senate Bill 248 FN relative to bail for
a defendant I make a motion that this
not be recommended for future
legislation seconded by representative
Stone um as I said we've already done
enough bail stuff I'd ask to call the
rooll vice chair roads yes
representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative janden yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
Harriet GTH yes representative
Balden yes representative Vale yes
representative
Murphy representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
celik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair V yes 170 170 the
motion carries it is not recommended for
future legislation with that I close the
executive session on Senate Bill
248 I open the executive session on
Senate Bill 321 and I make a motion that
it is not to be recommended for future
legislation second seconded by
representative rhods as I said this is
again an issue that was um taken care of
in our comprehensive bail package unless
anyone has anything to add I'd ask the
court to call the
role Vice chair rhs yes representative
Pratt yes representative
scitech representative jandrin yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative Harry GTH yes
representative
Balon yes representative veale yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative cig yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
chair votes yes 170 170 the motion
carries it is not recommended for fut
the legislation with that I close the
executive hearing on Senate Bill
321 with that I open the executive
session on Senate Bill 415 I Rec
recognize representative Pratt for a
motion make a motion in favor of future
legislation for Senate Bill 4
15 I
second um we've already discussed this
one I'm pretty sure where we all know
and come down on it so I'd ask cler col
roll excuse me representative UMES like
to U Echo something I heard before and
that's that I think the concept is great
uh but uh like some others I don't want
to vote for a mandatory minimum but I'll
hold my nose and vote for this uh but I
would not vote for it if it were
actually the Bill thank you and I would
add that probably neither would I I
think that it definitely needs work but
I do believe that we need to revisit the
strictness and uh comprehensive nature
of the of the subject matter could you
restate the motion please the motion is
to recommend for future legislation um
with that I ask cler call roll Vice
chair
roads representative Pratt yes
representative
scitec representative jandrin yes yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative Harry goth no
representative Balden no representative
Vale no representative Murphy yes
representative
Newman no uh the clerk votes no
representative Newell no representative
cig no representative
wheeler nay uh chairman Roy chair yes
it's 98 98 motion fails I'll entertain a
new motion oh excuse me the motion
passes I
did oh okay well I'll take that um then
motion carries it is recommended for
future legislation that I close the
executive session and I open the
executive session on uh excuse me
representative Pratt need a report by
the end of the week um I open the
executive session on Senate bill number
41 no excuse me 425
and relative to bail commission fees I
make a motion that it not be recommended
for fature legislation um can I have a
second seconded by representative Stone
this is again an issue that we took up
on our comprehensive bail packages is
now the law um so with that anyone wish
to add anything see none ask C call the
RO Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
Harry goth yes representative bden yes
representative veale yes representative
Murphy yes representative Newman yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative selig yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
cherot yes 170 170 motion carries it is
not recommended for future legislation
with that I close the executive session
on Senate Bill
425 and I open the executive session on
Senate Bill 464 relative to the
prohibiting of non-consensual
discimination of synthetic sexual images
and I'm looking for a
motion okay representative RADS thank
you Mr chairman I make a motion to not
recommend
464 seconded by representative
Murray um this is again one that we
discussed that um another bill we just
passed uh it was a house version of this
bill and representative Muse was one of
the sponsors so um I'd ask cl to call
the rooll unless somebody has anything
to add motion on the floor is not
recommend for future legislation Vice
chair roads yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec yes representative
janden yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative Harry ather yes
representative Balden yes representative
Vale yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes clerk votes
yes representative Newell yes
representative selig yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair vote Yes
170 170 motion carries it is not
recommended for future legislation I
hereby close the executive session on
Senate Bill 464 and I open the executive
session on Senate Bill 578 relative to
Criminal prear Tri services and
monitoring and I make a motion of not
recommend for future legislation can I
have a
second second by representative Stone um
again this is something that we
addressed in our our bail comprehensive
package that we directed that um the
commission the standing Commission on
criminal justice look into pre-trial
services and making it a Statewide um
possibility any further discussion on
that seeing none in s clert called the
role of the motion of floor is not
recommended for future legislation Vice
chair roads yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec yes representative
jren yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative Harry GTH no
representative Balon no representative
Vale no representative Murphy no
representative Newman no the clerk votes
no representative Newell no
Representative selig no
representative
wheeler n chairman Roy CHS 8 n motion
fails 89 um I'll entertain another
motion represent n like to make a motion
to recommend this for future
legislation need a second yeah second
seconded by representative G um again no
further discussion needed although I
thought we had kind of an agreement that
we already dealt with with this but okay
um I'd ask her to call the rooll motion
on the floor is to recommend for future
legislation Vice chair roads no
representative Pratt no Representative
scitec no Representative janen no
representative Manion no representative
Reed no representative Stone no
representative Harry goth yes
representative Balon yes representative
Vale yes representative m
yes representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative cig yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes no
98 98 motion carries the recommendation
is to recommend future legislation and
representative um nle I need a report by
the end of the week please
representative Katherine yeah can we go
back to 415 because I didn't get that
count the way it was yeah I was about to
bring up I think that it came up being
tied actually and not passing so I'm
going to let the record reflect that
that was a tie vote on that and um with
that there will be no recommendation
from the committee so um 88
88 yeah did one person not
vote I I think she maybe made the wrong
Vote or something vote yeah
be yeah I'm not going to revisit that
yeah it's 88 T um that's doesn't matter
just me no recommendation um anything
are you sure about that yeah we are we
kind just the numbers in the room tell
you that thank you for a fantastic B
anyia Mr chairman I think we worked
tremendously together I think we were
the best Committee in the legislature
and I watch a lot of them and I really
appreciate the work that you put in
making this committee work bipartisanly
and making us be able to get a lot of
good work done from this committee I
really appreciate that and I agree the
other committees do stink um qu question
yes question of our illustrious and
amazing chairman yes do we not need to
vote uh more than once to eventually
make no
recommendation do do we not have to fail
multiple votes I don't think so I think
if the vote is tied that means we
couldn't agree Oh I thought a tied vote
meant that the motion failed it doesn't
mean no recommendation unless a a a
different motion also fails I don't know
I don't know only one report is there
yeah there's only one report there's no
Minority Report on any of these so I
don't think that it would matter what
said there AE yeah that's what
we it's only a tie there's a tie that it
was a tie in that she voted um she voted
wrong no it was a tie not her voted was
a tie she that sheong would have
switched become 98 that's what I said
okay so it would be 98 okay so you have
to vote on the other the other motion
yeah we do why are you here I'll glad
make the
motion I he like exactly this okay here
let me let me fix this um I opened the
executive I reopen the exe can I even do
that I I reopen the executive session by
my magical power um on Senate bill which
one was it 415 and I recognize
representative Murphy to make a
motion fix
it uh I make a motion to not recommend
Senate Bill 415 relative to penalty for
certain fenel related offenses for
further um legislation okay seconded
seconded by Representative no I'd ask
the clerk to call the RO the motion
floor oh wait a minute don't we have to
undo the no because it failed I think we
have now we have
to question what uh can the clerk repeat
what the vote result was the first time
we voted on this the vote was 989 to
recommend but it was not what you wanted
it to be I'm sorry can you repeat that
the vote was 98 not to recommend and
representative Murphy voted on the
prevailing side in wait a minute if it's
not to recommend that's what you wanted
I'm mean to recommend I'm leaving okay
I'm sorry so it was 9 to8 and we have
that yeah she just is going to correct v
n in favor of not recom nine in favor of
recommending and eight against
recommending and there are 17 people in
this room so everyone voted yeah it so I
think the only way that if someone
messed up their vote the only way we
could change that is if someone makes a
motion to reconsider well no because
think about it she we vote she voted one
way right and that actually came out to
be tied didn't
it 9 to8 isn't that's
right oh my God the work we're doing on
a bill that can't go anywhere y like I
am the clerk and Bradley is here let us
talk about
it motion to reconsider is that what we
need to do so if if she voted the
wrong
then so recommendation
ofing that failed so you don't need to
Reb on
that
8 to vote not okay we don't need to
consider any of that it failed
so we're not recing it you don't need to
reconsider okay thank you I would ask
the clerk to quickly call the role on
the motion of not recommend for future
legislation we are voting on the motion
to recommend or yeah the motion is from
M Murphy to to recommend for future
legislation not to recommend
okay I'm gonna walk it through Mr chair
we need a point of order I thought she
wanted the
first one person at a
time the CL the first motion was to
recommend that motion prevailed by 9 to8
but representative Murray uh Murphy
voted on the prevailing side and error
we do not need to reconsider that vote
we just need to vote on a different
motion which representa of muru made to
not
recommend
yes to be on the safe side why don't you
why don't you vote to
reconsider representative representative
um Murphy will you withdraw your motion
please because we have to do another in
motion withdraw thank you um so I will I
will consider a new motion I'll make the
motion I move we Recon considered the
vote on what was this Senate Bill
4:15 and it was seconded by
representative G please call the role
the motion is to
reconsider VI chair roads yes
representative Pratt no representative
scitec yes representative janen yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed no repres representative
Stone no representative Harry goth yeah
representative Balden yes representative
Vale yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative suig yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair yes 143
okay now I will entertain a new
motion and that's Nancy you're up again
restive Murphy okay thank you um I move
that we um not recommend for future
legislation sen a bill 415 FN
second motion was seconded by
representative here Gite and ask the
cler to call the role the motion on the
floor is to not recommend for future
legislation Vice chair roads no
representative Pratt no representative
scitec Representative jandrin no
representative Manion no representative
Reed no representative Stone no
representative Harry GTH yes
representative Balden yes representative
Vale yes representative Murphy yes rep
representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell
yes yes with the side of Co
representative cig yes repres
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
chair votes no 98 the motion motion
carries 9 to8 it is not recommended for
future legislation representative Murphy
if you could get me a blur by the end of
the week with that I close the executive
session again on Senate Bill
4:15 and that is it we are in
recess where's the cake the cake was a
lie believe I was promised
cake
e
e for